We are getting ready to plan some travel for the holidays and so we've started to look on Airbnb We love to stay at an Airbnb because when you travel with children and your family It is nice to have a kitchen. It's nice to have you all in one area Jenna, I got a hot tip for you. What is it? Do you know that you could make money off of your home while you're away on vacation? Tell me more. I will. While you're away, your home could be an Airbnb.
Oh, really? Yeah, think about someone who's frequently traveling. You know? Yeah. While they're away, their home's making them money. That's pretty sweet. I know. That's very Shroot Farms of them. Although Dwight doesn't leave. That's pretty sweet. I know. That's very shrewt farms of them. Although Dwight doesn't
leave. That's true. And if he did leave, you'd be stuck with Moe's. Yes. Well, it sounds like Airbnb is a really practical way to earn some extra money. If you've stayed at an Airbnb, wouldn't it be cool to give that experience to others? Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at airbnb.com slash host. When does fast delivery through Instacart matter most? When your famous grainy mustard potato salad isn't so famous without its grainy mustard. When the barbecue's lit but there's nothing to grill. When the in-laws decide that actually they will stay for dinner. Instacart has all your groceries covered this summer. So download the app and get delivery
in as fast as 60 minutes. Plus enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders, service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Hello and welcome to your second drink of casino night. This is such a great episode. I mean, John Krasinski was with us. Yes, this was the first time John was on Office Ladies
and it was so fun. We got to reminisce about shooting those scenes in the parking lot and of course the behind the scenes of the Jim Pam kiss. I mean, it wasn't the first Jim and Pam kiss. No, it was not. I conceded that it was not their first kiss. You know, we also revisited Casino Night with director Ken Quapus,
who shared even more fun insights into this episode. And I mean, between these two podcasts, I really couldn't find anything we hadn't covered already. We really fleshed this one out. I did find a few questions in our general mailbag that I thought we could address. Okay. So the first one is for you, Ange,
and it is from Rachel M. in Genoa, Illinois, who said, I'm watching all the super fan episodes, so it shows the deleted scenes, which I love, but during the deleted scene for Casino Night at one minute and 41 seconds, you see Angela smile about, quote, irritating Cylons for the Mad Libs. Angela, were you breaking character in that moment?
Well, Rachel, you know what? Thank you for writing in. I was really curious. I didn't remember that exact moment, so I went back and rewatched it, and I'm actually not breaking. I actually made the choice that Angela's being a little flirty and is delighted to be sitting next to Dwight, and she's very charmed by him. Okay, so this was flirty smile, not breaking smile.
That's right. I mean, listen, anytime Angela smiles, we have to wonder. I know, and I never was given permission really to like laugh or smile, so when I did, I got very excited. All right, next question is from Amelia G in Australia. Amelia says, I have a question for you both. It's more of a, what do you think happened question? So after Pam and Jim's kiss on what we assume was a Friday night,
how long do you think it was before he moved to Stanford? Jenna, did you have in your PAM file what that Monday morning was like for both of them as we never see or hear about it? Well, Amelia, I did think a lot about this after this episode because I knew that this was our season finale and that there was gonna be a time jump for the next season and Jim was gonna be somewhere else.
And I wondered when did he make that move? And I always imagine that he took Jan up on her offer. Well, he has that talking head. He's like, I might as well take her up on it. I mean, I have no future here. Yes. I imagine that he did that like Saturday. Like, he was like, I'm going to take you up on it.
I don't know if he ever came back to the office. I'm sure he did to get his things. So I'm sure there was, like, an awkward few days. But I think he was out of there pretty quickly. That's my feeling. That tracks for me, too. I think the other question that I really wondered about was, like, when in that timeline did Pam call off the wedding?
Was it after Jim left and how long after and yeah. But that was a pretty big summer for both of them. It sure was. Well, our last question is from Fiona L. in Melbourne who said, hi, office ladies. In the commentary for Casino Night, Jenna talks about how when she and John were standing out near the car, and Jim first tells Pam that he's in love with her, Jenna was very excited and distracted
at what good acting John was doing, and she couldn't wait for him to see it. So I'm wondering, Jenna and Angela, can you tell us about any times on the show when, Jenna, you've been blown away by Angela's performance, or Angela, that you've been blown away by Jenna's performance? What comes to mind? Oh, well, there's so many for you, Jenna.
I mean, you have so many great moments as Pam. I always think about that talking head when Jim pops in and asks you out to dinner. And everything that played across Pam's face in such a brief moment, like what you were able to do, the journey you took us on of all these years and hoping for this moment and right there on your face. And it's not even like you had a scene partner really, you had to sort of just have that moment come over you.
So I always am blown away by that. I mean, for me, it's your moment with Oscar in season nine when you take him up on his offer to stay with him after you've left the senator. I just love that scene, and I love your work in that scene. But I feel like Fiona is wondering if we've ever been in a scene, and while we're in the scene,
were we distracted by each other? By each other. Oh, I see, I see. And the one that popped into my mind was the duel, By each other? By each other. Oh, I see, I see. And the one that popped into my mind was the duel, because I remember you having to sort of like hold all of us in the bullpen with your speech. Right. And I remember watching that and like being distracted by the fact that like you were being like the Steve Carell of that day, you know, and just be like, oh my gosh, I can't wait for my friend to see herself in this moment.
Oh, I love that. Honestly, like when we were in the big bullpen and there were the scenes where Pam would take on Ryan in whatever stupid thing he was saying. And I was in the scene with you, so I'm not supposed to be looking at you with like awe, like you go Pam, you get him. But I would have to check myself because I'd be like, oh, that's so good. I'm like totally lost in the moment. But yeah, I loved it when Pam, like when you as Pam like went up against someone, whether it was Michael or Ryan or Dwight, and it was always a big group scene,
whether it was the conference room or bullpen, and you just held your own and did your thing. It was always so fun to watch. Aw, well, hey, thanks Fiona for letting us reminisce. That's all I got, folks. I mean, we really covered it. Please enjoy this second drink of Casino Night. And if you want to follow up with Casino Night Revisited
with director Ken Quapus, we're not going to be playing it in our second drinks, but you can find it on OfficeLadies.com, episode number 36. And here is Casino Night. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Lady luck, roll those dice, it's casino night everyone. Oh luck, roll th night everyone. Oh baby. excited for this episode.
this since it aired until episode and Angela, oh my good. It was a saw God re we get started. You guys, you know, we're right now. Yep. And it's if you hear some rain, tha to move into my daughter' rain outside of my closet
like I was tinkling the wanted to sound like inap I know there's rain, but then you know how sometimes the rain happens to come off of a gutter in a sort of waterfalls way. Apparently, that's what happens outside of my closet. So I'm in my my daughter's closet. because all three kids are inside and loud. They're so loud. And I'm just like what? I can't tell them to like not make any noise ever. Yeah. Okay, so here we go. Casino Night.
I'm so excited. Season two, episode 22, written by Steve Carell. Steve Carell. All right, written by Steve Carell, directed by Ken Quapus. This is already off to a good start, Jenna. Oh yeah, this is a good team. All right, hit me with a summary. Here we go.
Michael decides to hold a casino night down in the warehouse to benefit charity. However, Michael is going to have to juggle two dates. Mm-hmm. Bum, bum, bum. Also, J his possible transfer to And that's going to lead
with Pam. It's a good one some Sam fast facts. Yeah number one written by Steve Carell. So here's something that maybe a lot of people don't know. Steve also co-wrote 40 Year Old Virgin. This is not the first thing that Steve has written. So he got to write this episode. You know, he also wrote another episode of The Office season for episode seven
Survivor Man. So we'll get to that one. But I found an old article from the LA Times where Steve did an interview all about how he came to be the writer of this season two finale. Lady, that is some good detective work. I love it. I was very proud of myself. Alright, so here's how it went down. So Steve had the idea as a general episode that Michael should throw a casino night down in the warehouse. And he pitched that idea to Greg and Greg said, Oh, that would make a great setting for the finale episode. And then I guess remember when Steve had to fly to New York to do the Valentine's Day episode on the airplane. Steve and Greg were together and on the way there and on the way back,
they sat down, they sort of plotted out together what the finale would be with this casino night idea. Isn't that incredible? Oh my god, that's amazing! They're on the plane and they're outlining this episode. I love that. And Greg said to Steve, why don't you write it? You should write it. And Steve was like, okay, yeah, I mean, I think that's great.
But then this is a really fun tidbit. Steve got cold feet. Oh, and he tried to get out of it. Oh, so I guess this was during the time when he was still doing Evan Almighty on the weekends, you know, he would shoot on our show. Sometimes like four days a week, we would shoot him out in four days and then he would fly and on the weekends he would be doing Evan Almighty. And so he flew home and he had one weekend
to write this finale script and his parents were in town visiting him at his house. And so he went into Greg's office. And he said, there's, I just don't think I can do it justice. There's no way I can do it. I should get out of it. But Steve had this great quote where he said, I don't know, Greg managed to talk him into doing it anyway. Like Greg has a way where by the time he was leaving Greg's office, he was like, I'm writing this episode again. How did that happen? I should not get out of it. So.
That makes me smile because it's very Greg. Greg, you know, we've sort of all said that he was kind of like our dad. Yeah. Although he's not old enough to be our dad, obviously, but he had sort of that father mentor thing of like, you'll figure it out. You're gonna do it.
It's gonna be okay. And then you're like, wait, what? It's gonna be great. Wait, I can totally see that. I came in here to tell you I'm not doing it. And what? Wait, what? Now I'm writing it.
Yeah. But he did say he was really pumped. That was the other part of it was that Greg really infused him with this enthusiasm. So he was really excited. So what he did was he went home and he would write the script after his parents went to bed. Aw.
So he would stay up at night and write the script and he turned it in. And he said then the writing staff did a bunch of punch ups and like they usually do. And that's how we got the script. Wow, way to go Steve. Way to like- Isn't that crazy? Man, I love that story.
All right, that was a good one. Moving on to fast fact number two. This is a supersized episode. Greg said that he was doing an interview for the Chicago Tribune, and he had mentioned in the interview kind of casually that he wished that the finale for season two could be supersized.
Well, this started a whole online petition by office fans. They started writing in like crazy to NBC, give me my remote, Northern Attack and office tally started these online petitions. And it was the fans that got us the supersized episode. That's great. And you know what, this was before Twitter and Instagram, it was not easy to start an online petition back then. Yeah, no, you didn't have the same outreach. And they really just like kept at it. And NBC was like, okay.
And Greg was thrilled. Thank you so much to the Office fans for making that happen because I could not imagine this episode being 22 minutes. There's so much we would have missed. I wish this episode was an hour. I could have watched even more. I know, but I kind of feel like that
about almost all the episodes. But this one in particular, I'm so happy with Longer. That's what she said. That's what she said. Well, speaking of Longer, this podcast is probably also gonna be supersized today because, well, we're gonna have a special guest join us later.
Jenna and I got to talk to someone about this episode and this person was such a delight. Jenna, we talked for like almost an hour. We did. And we just want y all. So buckle in, it's g episode. It is, it's gonna Bum bum bum, wink, wink,
three, we got a lot of qu about what it was like to into a casino. I mean, se we talk about this for a we talk about Dunder Mifl transform the warehouse i mean, seriously, can we t second? Can we talk about budget for parties? I mea planning committee, I usua and a cake that I mean an
cloth. It's true. But then a booze cruise. He throws night. Where is he getting the money for this? At eight seconds, Jenna, you see them converting the warehouse and there's all these extra employees. There's giant neon signs. There's dealers.
I mean, where is this budget coming from? That I don't know. That I don't know. But I did reach out to Kentopedia to find out how we transformed the warehouse into a casino and this is what he said. He said that he hired a company that specialized in creating casinos for special events
like Christmas parties or college fundraisers. I've been to those things. I've been to fundraisers that are casino nights. And so there are these companies and they send dealers, they send all the equipment. And so he just said he hired one of those companies and then he used all the employees from the company as extras in the episode. What was this budget? I'm sorry, I can't stop talking about the budget, but it was it was crazy. Do you think we raised more money than the party cost? No.
No. It was definitely a loss. It was a loss, for sure. Speaking of the whole casino setup, fan question from ExplorinLauren, she asked, in between scenes, did you all play any poker games? Did you, Amj? Did you play any of the games?
No, I didn't. Did you? Oh, yeah. You did? Oh, yeah. There were any time that I was sitting. You love poker. I know. And it was professional dealers. So my character was stationed at the poker tables too. So whenever I was in the background of any scenes, I was sitting at a poker table and we played poker. It was like the greatest time. I mean I have a memory of like sitting and watching you guys play cards because I really didn't know how to play poker. I only just
learned I'm not great. I mean I always think I can win with a pair of threes. I'm that I'm basically Phyllis. You can I know but I'm basically you know Phyllis, look, the one with the flower one, yeah, the clovers. But a lot of you guys were poker players. I mean, Rain had a poker tournament, didn't he? In his garage or something. You guys all went. Yeah, it was the people who played the most together outside of work were me, Rain, David Denman, Chris Workman and Ed Nielsen Jr. Those guys were on the crew. And I'm trying to think who else, but there was a little group of us, like six or eight of us,
and we would go to Rain's garage and play poker on the weekends. Yeah, so I love that you guys were doing that in between scenes. I'm sure I just was sitting there being chatty. Well, listen, I think we should take a break and get into this episode because like we said, it is a long one.
So we'll be right back. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. I just had a visit with my mom and I was kind of thinking about all the ways that she has really informed my life as an adult. And one of the things that I really admire about her is that she was always willing to ask for help when she needed it. For advocating for herself. Yeah. Well you know mental health awareness is growing now but there's still progress to be made. 26 percent of Americans who
participated in a recent survey say they have avoided seeking mental health support due to fear of judgment. Well this Mental Health Awareness Month, let's encourage everyone to take care of their well-being and break the stigma. Better Help is fully online. It's making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. And you can easily switch therapists anytime at no cost. We're all better with help. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today
to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. I'm Emma Greede and I've spent the last 20 years building, running and investing in some incredible businesses. The more success I've had, the more people started coming to me with questions. How do you start a business? How do you raise money? How do I bounce back from failure? On my new podcast, Aspire with Emma Greed, I'll be answering these questions and more through weekly conversations with the smartest minds out there. Listen to and follow Aspire with Emma Greed, an Odyssey podcast available now,
wherever you get your podcasts. There are very few things that you can be certain of in life. But you can always be sure the sun will rise each morning. You can bet your bottom dollar that you'll always need air to breathe and water to drink. And of course, you can rest assured that with Public Mobile's 5G subscription phone plans, you'll pay the same thing every month. With all of the mysteries that life has to offer, a few certainties can really go a long way.
Subscribe today for the peace of mind you've been searching for. Public Mobile. Different is calling. Okay, we are back. And let's get into this episode, Jenna. We've got a lot of ground to cover and at 36 seconds Dwight's in a tuxedo. Game on. It's starting. Oh yeah, he explains that it's a family heirloom. His grandfather was buried in it. Yeah, so that's special. And now you have a Jim Pam prank. right? Can we talk for one quick second
about the fact that Pam winks at Jim with Roy right there? I have that down, I have that down. So yes, Roy and Pam, they're talking about casino night. This starts a whole conversation about who can win roulette. Right? Jim says he can win by using mind control. And Dwight says, oh really? You can do mind control.
Why don't you try moving the coat rack? So he stares at it and it moves to everyone's surprise. And then Pam winks at Jim. And I wrote down, discuss, how do we feel about this? It's a big wink. It's not like, and Roy is right there. Is he, yeah, does he not have eyes? Is he not looking at his fiance?
What the hell, why are you winking at Jim? So the flirt is starting early on. This is early. For sure. Early in the evening. It's not even the evening, it's the day. The flirt is starting early on. This is early. For sure early in the evening. It's not even the evening. It's the day. Well, I starting I had a fan question from batya who said was the wink Pam gave Jim scripted? Yes, it was I was gonna say absolutely. It was it was in the script. I actually I
have the script from this episode Angela. I love that you have the script. What did what so you What go to it? Yeah, I looked there. It says Pam winks another fan question to f the cold open Jenna, did coat rack with an umbrella Jenna what in a time caps capsule called the DVD commentary you talk about it. Oh I went into it? Yeah you went into it. You said that there was a crew member that had a string.
It was like a clear like fishing line. We tried to have me do it. We tried to have me use the little even like tried to have me use that string thing and you just saw my arm moving too much. I was too far away. Like the umbrella with the hook on the end, I couldn't even reach the coat rack with it. I was going to say the coat rack is actually further away from you than people realize. Yeah. It's actually quite far from you. But the optical illusion makes it kind of seem like I could have, but no, I wasn't really doing it. And then Pam is very proud of herself because she has a silent
talking head where she's showing off the umbrella. And Jenna, you're like as Pam, you are beaming. You're so proud of that moment. I know. Well, I think it's meant, you know, that wasn't set up that whole idea of mind control. I think the idea of that was that in the moment, Pam figured out how to have Jim's back. Yeah. And so I think she's like, that's where the wink comes from. And that's why she's so proud. Exactly. She's super proud. They didn't know Dwight was going to pick the coat rack. Pam didn't know that Jim was going to set that up. No. Yeah, she's like, Look what I did. Oh my god.
I know. I had another fan question, Angela. This is from Chelsea Glover. Were there any deleted scenes that you're sad didn't make the final cut? And actually, there is an original cold open to this episode. This little prank bit with the coat wrap, this was actually originally meant to go after the credit sequence. And there's a whole cold open that was cut out, but that you can see on the DVD extras.
Did you watch it, Angela? It's where Michael brings us into the conference room and makes us do a Dunder Mifflin themed mad lib. Mad libs, yes, it's great. Yeah. So I, I kind of cool, but we didn' had to cut it out. Well, l big thing to point out. I of you guys were thinking
to be talking about it. I stop for a moment. What i one second, there's a new plant at reception. A new potted plant. There is a yellow flowering plant at reception. This is a big deal, guys. We got so much mail about this.
We got no mail about it. But I always crack up whenever Pam. I feel like it's Pam brings in a plant and then it doesn't live very long, but she tries. That's my backstory. She tries to it's like casino night. I'll buy a plant at the, you know, at the pharmacy. They have those plants by the checkout.
I'll buy one. She's doing her best. She's trying to cheer to the reception de the scene where Michael i Jan. Uh, she's trying to about what's going on wit he just invites her to ca
she's like Michael, she's and he wants to have this elaborate party that costs so much money. Yeah And she's just like Michael. I'm not I'm not coming to that but mmm Maybe later Something else. Okay. So next up at four minutes 11 seconds Michael's in the bullpen. He's sitting on Pam's desk Mm-hmm. Pam's explaining that we're hav the beneficiary is Boy Sc the big winner of the ni
$500 to donate to the cha and a mini fridge comple Yes, to which Phyllis is proud. If you freeze at f Phyllis is so proud. Oh my gosh. So proud. If you freeze at four minutes, 34 seconds, Phyllis's face, she actually sticks her tongue out. It's like, what? She's so happy that Vance Refrigeration is donating the prize. But before we get there, I have to point out a great screen grab at four minutes, 14 seconds.
For those of you guys that have been tuning in. I talk about what I call the accountant stack. It's how they stack the accounting department to get them in the bullpen right because we're tucked around the corner. Yeah so you wouldn't see us so they would pull us out in this formation and it's the best screen grab of it I have seen yet. It is me at the copier with Oscar just like two feet behind me and then Brian like three feet seen yet. It is me at the copier with Oscar just like two feet behind me and then Brian like three feet behind Oscar. It is like literally we look like a row of dominoes and it's so we could be in the scene and react.
That is perfect. I remember that they would do that and sometimes it would make no sense that everyone else was able to sit at their desks and listen to Michael, but you guys would have to get up and walk over a little bit and stand. And during those seats you have to stand the whole time. Yes, I would be so envious of people that got to sit through really long scenes because we'd just be standing by the copier. Oh, that's a good thing when you're re-watching these episodes for people to just know how often the accountants are standing up. Yeah, while everyone else is sitting. So then we lead into this series of talking heads where
everyone explains where they would donate the money should they be the big winner for the night. And you know Creed has a talking head where he says he's going to give the money to a soup kitchen He's going to give the money to a soup kitchen. Yeah. That has a really delicious pea soup on Thursdays. Oh, creed. Creed. Kevin says to animals or people, once again reminding us, is maybe not the smartest person. Angela, you have a great talking head.
So much sass. I am not wanting to participate in this casino night. I say that we're j money that's from gamblin drugs or prostitute ourse that money to charity. I she's a not happy because plan this party. B is gam
alcohol, but Jenna, she s gonna show up later to Yeah, she does. So this l favorite scenes with some of all time ever from the what you're saying. I know talk about. Michael annou the night, they're going
check to some boy scouts. He's so him, right? He's so de can have a giant check an Oh, actually, Michael, th then he lists the many re be inappropriate to have casino night. He's like g It's in a dangerous wareh night, Hooters is catering, do I
need to say more? Yeah, do I need to go on? So this leads to the classic Michael line. Why are you the way that you are? Michael Sass, I wrote Michael Sass. Michael Sass. This next line is my most absolute favorite, Angela. Mm-hmm. I hate so much about the things that you choose to be.
I could not get through that. So that whole thing that Michael says like that, why are you the way that you are? All of that was scripted. It's in the script word for word. So good. Then Michael announces that he is going to donate to Afghanistan is with AIDS. Well, we got a fan question from Augusta.
She said one of my absolute favorite scenes of all time is the Afghan Afghanistan scene. Was any of that improvised or was that all scripted? All right, I went to the script and mostly all scripted, with the exception of one line, which is John Krasinski. He improvised Afghanistanis. He was supposed to just say Afghanistan's. Way to go, John.
Well, is it a good way to put a way to go. Way to put to you about what happens seconds. Oh yeah. Because happy. Oh my gosh. So hap Roy was gonna to pick the band, but now he's too busy planning his bachelor party. I mean, how many red flags does someone need? She's planning her wedding with the guy she's in love with that's not her fiance. Yeah. And then Jim has the line that breaks your heart at eight minutes he says I mean I talked to Jan about a transfer because I have no future here yeah he has no future there I know I know so now they go you know we're jumping around a little but let's let's see this Jim Pam moment through
okay lady all right they're in the conference room they're watching these band videos. By the way we got a ton of questions about Brian's drumming. So many people wrote in. Yes so they put in a tape and they realized oh my gosh that's Kevin. Yeah. Kevin is in a band. Guess who came up with the band name Scrantonicity? Who? Mindy. Really? That was Mindy. That was Mindy. That's, that was her idea. That name. Well, check this out. When I looked at this scene in the script, the name of the band is not Scrantonicity.
Oh yeah, what was it? Jokers and Tokers. So I texted Brian because we got a lot of questions about, is he really drumming? Is hem singing? Yeah. And I also of this jokers and tokers told me that he is actua a Steve Miller song in th he says he's playing, but
faking it because he did to drum until later when his band had t it Phyllis's wedding? Ye stage, right? Yeah. So he his way through the song. this whole scene of him a could not get permission use the song. So in post
a police tribute band and the's when they changed the name to Scrantonicity and Brian had to dub his voice singing Don't Stand So Close to Me. And that's what they ended up playing. So if you watch that video, the lyrics do not match his mouth. I didn't notice it until after Brian told me all this stuff though. Oh, that's good. I noticed it until after all this stuff though. Oh based on this knowledge. hand putting the tape int
later. I remember having to do a pickup of John's hand putting in Scrantonicity. Okay. And then later in the warehouse, you know, Roy is gonna come up to Kevin and he's gonna say, hey, I heard about your band Scrantonicity, right? This happens at 22 minutes and 5 seconds. Yeah. The band name is said off-camera. It's Roy's voice, but on-camera is Kevin and they had to dub that too. That was some good behind the scenes tidbits for Scrantonicity lady. I know. Thank you, Brian Baumgartner. Okay, so we're jumping around a bit but back at 8 minutes 16 seconds.
We have Darryl in Michael's office. He's like look, I'm not having fire eaters in a paper warehouse. So why does he want fire eaters at a casino night anyway? Let me tell you, he would have a full circus in there if he could. He wants it bigger, louder, crazier. And then Dwight enters for quote protection. And then there's this very funny exchange where we learn that Darryl has taught phrases to Michael to help him with his interracial conversations.
We learn about dink and flicka. Dink and flicka. This handshake. And Daryl has a great talking head. And Jenna, I'm pretty sure that this is Craig Robinson's very first talking head, I think in this episode. I think it is.
Well, Angela, I looked up dink and flicka on Urban Dictionary. You did? Oh yeah. Does it reference the office? Yes. It says made popular in a recent episode of The Office, Dink and Flicka roughly translates to That's Life or C'est la vie. I sort of remember that as talking about that Dink and Flicka and that Steve had just made it up. I don't know if I'm remembering that wrong. But I think that is just out of Steve
Correll's mind. Also Fleece it out. But I thin of Steve Correll's mind. out. That was another on the urban dictionary. I k these two made up phrases urban dictionary as sort Way to go. Steve Correll Well, there is some delici up. Oh yes. Okay. All rig so much. I this is one of way to go Steve Correll. delicious Pam sass coming
All right. I love this bi is one of the things our love work. We find out in something a character has but we didn't know it and those moments. So at 10 m still calls and Pam's's on the phone and where she doesn't let it
like still me, still me. to. She says Michael is b attempt. He's better at h people because the first ridiculous thing. What di down? What does he say to He says, Hey Carol, how's Is it real good? Pam's li
and then the second time normal. Yeah, he's like, up. It's so good. And the This is a great scene. So with Carol and she just n for his mortgage insuranc happens. This is a great Michael's on the phone wi just needs one last signat insurance. That's why she tells Carol you should co
and she's like, um, yeah the signature or she's, i little confusing what he' Nancy did such a great jo been like, wait to your p your party. That's where I get the signature. Yes, we should remind people guys, Carol stills played by Nancy Correll, Steve's wife in real life. So then the other line, Pam's putting through another call. It's Jan. And Jan is calling to tell Michael, Michael, I would love to come to Casino Night.
I feel like you can watch Steve as Michael, like literally break into a sweat. He's like, holy crap. When in a million years did I think that I'd have two women on the line who both just said yes to me within seconds of each other. Two queens on casino night. Gonna have to drop a deuce. Oh boy. So that's that's a big cliffhanger. We go into like what would normally be a commercial break right there. Should we go into a break? Let's go into a break because now we're gonna get into the casino game and a lot, a lot is going to happen. All right, we are back and we are at the casino.
The casino is open. Gambling is happening. It's open for business. At 13 minutes, 22 seconds, it is happening, Jenna. You are wearing quite the dress. Oh, everyone got very dressed up for this. We got a You are wearing quite the dress. Oh, everyone got very dressed up for this. We got a ton of mail about your dress. Matt Mabe said, how many different dresses did you try on before you settled on the blue one that you wore?
Danny Thurigood said, my wife has a theory that the dress Pam wears was an old bridesmaids dress that Pam had in her closet. Danny, I wrote on a note card, Pam in a bridesmaids dress? Question mark. It really looks like a bridesmaids dress. It really does. Yes. And then original Gus Girl said, whose decision was it for Pam to wear her watch with her gown? It was a subtle, but great costuming and character choice. I love all of these questions. You guys are so observant. All right, let me start by saying Angela and Danny's wife, you guys are correct. Was it a bridesmaid's dress? Well, it was that was the inspiration when I met with Carrie, our wardrobe designer about this outfit that Pam would wear. We said,
want her to be dressed up dress. But on Pam's salari about Pam's life, when w a cocktail dress and she' to buy one just for casin a whole conversation wher know what? I think she re night. So we had a whole we were like, you know wh re wears an old bridesmae
the fanciest thing she has what she wears. I'll have the first dress I tried o had a whole rack of dress all on. That was our favor picture to Greg and he approved it immediately. It was like a winner from the start. Well that is so great and perfect and really answers my burning question because I was like that I feel like I wore a bridesmaids dress that looks similar
to that yeah to a wedding in the 90s. By the way I love that watch question Angela because that was a discussion. It was a discussion that w because that was a discu that Pam wears that watch the time you can't see it would come up to me and h and it had my watch and i ring on it or my Pam enga you pick it up, you put i
in the morning, take it o night. And so I've always been wearing that watch, but you cannot normally see it because it's underneath my sleeve, right? So we had a whole discussion, does Pam wear her watch with her fancy dress or not? And we thought, listen, guys, this is back before iPhones. You didn't have the time in your back pocket
the way you do now. And we discussed that Pam does not have a fancy watch. So she's got one watch and she wore it. And I can't believe someone noticed that detail. Thanks for noticing. Pam would wear her watch. That made such sense to me. I love it.
I feel like she also probably has a pair of Keds on standby that she can change into. I love that. Angela, what about your dress? You're wearing a black dress which is in your color scheme but I mean it's a it's a little bit it's a bit what sultry it's somewhat tight. It's an LBD for sure it is a little black dress I, I have a little bit of cleavage. Yeah, a little bit. A little bit. It is a tight little black dress. I feel like she probably wore it to a funeral and maybe it had some lace attachment over her decollage. But maybe she's feeling a little a little
saucy. So she was like, I'm not gonna wear this sweater that goes with it. I do have a sweater that comes in and out of scenes I don't know if you notice at right at the top I'm holding it and then later on you see me wearing it but um yeah I know I'm wearing a little black dress. I have to point out it's jumping around but I have a great catch of someone breaking character. Oh and that's someone is me at 13 minutes 24 seconds there is a shot of Angela Martin talking to Meredith and you see at the very beginning of the moment maybe I'm aware that camera's panning over and so I have a solemn look and then clearly I think camera has gone off of us and then
I just go I just like start gesturing and I think I can make out the words I have to pee or something. Oh my gosh, what else is going on? Are you in the background of another scene? I'm in the background of an establishing shot of you and Roy gambling. And then it pans over to the rest of us.
Jim's at another table, I'm talking to Meredith, I'm holding my sweater an of it, I have a solemn fa seconds, I think the camera start being chatty. It's Oh my gosh. All right, sh now, let's get into it. C chips. Carol has arrived.
wingman, I guess. And Toby at cards. Yes. And I have arrive. Dwight is Michael and Toby just beat Michael and I have a few fan quest The first one comes from She says Dwight is a terr inability to warn Michael is great. Was any of that So I looked at the script and You know when Carol first arrives and Dwight comes up and says code remax is here But no sign of land Jevinson. Yeah, it's so good. That second part was improvised
So I'm not sure I know I'm not sure brain did it or if it was like one of the writer pitches on set because we would have writers on set That would pitch us jokes not your brain did it or of the writer pitches on have writers on set that jokes. But the original l be no sign of date number very funny because it is also out loud. He says Mi All right. So Jenna at 18
I have a card called kiss Oh, this is a classic. Th Angela moment. It's when crafts and Angela walks u dress and she's like, wha they're very formal with very formal and he's like to roll an eight and everyone wins. And she says, so roll an eight.
And then he does. Yes! And he is so excited that he grabs you and he kisses you on the cheek. I know! And listen, even though maybe she's happy about that, she has to slap him for being inappropriate at work. Yes. Well, Angela, we got a fan question from Heather Lindo. Sam, will you play it?
Hi, Jenna. Hi, Angela. Casino Night is one of my very favorite episodes for a lot of reasons. And one of them being the scene at the craps table when Dwight kisses Angela for good luck, and then she slaps him. but when she turns around her face is just perfection. She cycles through like 10 emotions in a matter of like three seconds. She is horrified and thrilled and embarrassed and obviously deep down very happy all at the same time and I just love it. And Angela, my question is did you nail that on the first take or did you have to do it many, many times?
Thank you so much for letting me ask my question. I know everyone says this, but my sister Kim and I really are the Office number one fans. We just love you so much, so thank you. Oh my God, Heather! That was so sweet, I love that question so much. Okay, so I was very excited about this question because I actually wrote in my journal about the scene, of course you did. Of course we did I wrote about it the week we filmed it to answer your question Heather
No, I did not get it right the first time. Okay, so I wrote that I was really nervous to slap rain at first You know, my slap was kind of timid which makes sense because you were probably very you were worried about hurting him slap was kind of timid, w you were probably very, y about hurting him. Exactly hurt him and it wasn't a told you to really slap h were never did a phony sl
a real slap and well I gu slap wasn't working. So R just go for it. I can tak really slapping him. And I wrote that it took us about 13 takes to get home. That's 13 slots. All right. Here's the one thing I need you guys to remember. I am five one rain is like six three. So it wasn't really easy for me to reach his cheek. And one time my aim was really off and I missed his cheek and I slapped his ear so hard. He was like, I'd actually heard him. You said there was like a ringing in his ear. And then the other time I missed and I slapped and I hit his glasses
and I knocked them sideways on his face. I know. I know. Well, I want to go back to something that Heather said too about that look on your face as you're walking away. Yeah. Because it is, it is amazing. And I have the script and I looked it up and all it says is that you slapped white and that you smile as you walk away from the table. I think there's so much more going on in your face. So your character is angry that Dwight would kiss you so publicly and all of that. But what I love is that you have this little look to the camera at the very end. It's like 18 minutes, 48 seconds. Yeah. Where you sort of catch the camera catching you smiling. That camera catch was not in the script. Was that improvised?
Yes, it was. Okay, so that just happened on the day, that little moment where I'm busted at the end. So in one of the early takes, I was walking out of frame and I just looked at camera and I quickly looked away. Like I was embarrassed that they caught me smiling. And our director of photography, Randall Einhorn said, Ange, Ange, I caught it. I caught it right at the end as you're leaving frame.
And he really helped me find that moment. Then he showed it to our director. Our director loved it. And so Randall was like, Ange, you don't have a lot of time to cycle through all that, but I'm going to catch it every time if you glance to camera and quickly look away embarrassed. So I have to thank Randall for that. Cause he really helped me make that moment happen. I love that.
Yes. All right folks out there that love background catches. I have one more moment for you in this little scene at 18 minutes, 51 seconds. You can really see how red the side of Rain's face is. And it's because I have slapped him 13 times. Ha! Well, there you have it. Heather, thank you for such a great question.
Thank you, Heather. I love that question. Okay, so Angela, you just described the big kind of Dwight Angela flirt moment that happens in front of everybody at the at the casino night. So now we head over to the poker table where it is heads up between Jim and Pam. And I feel like this is the big Jim Pam flirt moment that's public. There is so much
flirting happening. Pam is basically doing the giggle hair toss move from about last night. I mean, there it is on it is so much flirting happening. is basically doing the g it is on, it is on. Well, from live love California, faces back and forth. Was between us, there was a and so what you're seeing is John and I's interpretation. This is what it says right after Jim's line. You're bluffing. Pam makes a playful gesture like who knows? Jim stares at her intensely. She smiles her best enigmatic smile. Jim enjoys this woman so much, he finally has to break eye contact and shake it off. Oh.
So that was what John and I, we had to take that note in the script and that's what made that scene. Oh, that's so good. I love that. Yeah. I love that. Well, I have a question that's not related
to you guys flirting, but at 19 minutes, 26 seconds, what the heck? So Kevin wears glasses when he plays poker, but he doesn't wear glasses to be an accountant. Angela, we literally got a fan question that said the same thing. What's up? My theory about that is that he doesn an accountant. I know. Bu us, he has won one of the the world series of poker player. This guy, he's a playing poker. He's a sma
playing poker. But also w in his band, he wears a h he comes to the barbecue, he's got a whol of the office that is ver what we see on a daily ba sure. I want to follow th is he, is he putting us a
really have to do work? W Okay, we have to talk abo Carol and Jan are now sid the bar. Oh yeah. Okay, we have to talk about 20 minutes, three seconds. Carol and Jan are now side by side at the bar. Oh yeah. Okay, so I took a screen grab of them standing side by side. You know I'm friends with Nancy, Steve's wife. I just adore her so much.
I texted her the photo and I'm like, Nancy, this is how I'm starting my morning. And she was like, oh my God. She said, first of all, WTF with my hair. I said, Nancy, what do you remember about shooting these scenes? And she said, oh my gosh, well, our kids were six and three. So I had very few functioning brain cells at that point. And I said, well, Nancy, what was it like working with Steve?
And she said, Ange, I was so intimidated because he's so good. I mean, he was really nice to me, of course. But I've sort of, you know, I had retired and having our kids. That's what I was doing. I was being a mom, so I felt a little rusty, but it was so much fun. Oh, she is so great. And Steve's face would just light up every time she came to set. Either if she was in a scene or if she was just coming by with the kids for a visit. I mean his adoration of her was just would go all across his face. Oh, they just were the cutest of cutie cutes as a couple.
They are an adorable couple. They are so sweet with one another. I just loved them get so excited to when Nan scenes because we were of makeup at the same time an gab and gab and gab. I ju So now Michael is at the c
has both Carol and Jan blo luck. So weird, so weird, this is where Dwight starts peppering Jan with questions about where are you staying tonight? He's naming all the motels. And then Dwight has this line where he's like, Oh, were you planning to stay with Michael? Well, that was not in the script. Oh, it wasn't? No, no. I feel like that when I heard that, I went to the script to look because I'm like, that sounds like a rain improv to me. That's brilliant rain. So good. So good.
Yes. So good. I think she was legitimately surprised that he said it. Yeah, I texted Malora. I told her she's so fantastic in this episode. You just really feel Jan's desperation. And then you feel herself loathing. It's, oh, it's so layered. So now we go over to the poker table with Kevin and Phyllis. Mm-hmm. Phyllis the flapper. Phyllis the flapper.
Phyllis the flapper. He goes all in against Phyllis, and she wins with a flush. But she thought she only had ace high. But no, she ace and she is like, I ha I texted Phyllis and I sa you remember about that p wrote me and said, oh, I game. Brian's faces kevin
won. And then she r watching Pam and Jim flir it looked real because th actors. Oh, no, she's the said it was a priceless e you and Jenna. Oh, well l what? Jan is gonna walk minutes 37 seconds because she's just over it and she's outside smoking and Jim walks out and lady I don't know
if you remember this but at the time when this aired so many people thought that Jim and Jan were maybe going to hook up in this moment and they were freaking out on all the message boards. Oh my God. Yeah. I really like Oh, no, no. Are they gonna hook up? But no, they're just having a heart to heart. And then you find out the stakes for Jim, right? That he Yeah, she's like, have you told anyone? Because he's gonna transfer but yeah people thought they might hook up and they were all like no yeah so now we go back inside Bob Vance is making an announcement he's gonna announce who the big winner of the night is he said it's Creed Bratton okay and he wins a refrigerator and Creed says I've never owned a refrigerator oh my god this is this first one. T first refrigerator. So he
we are to the jam tastic There is going to be a bi lot. There's going to be the office. So we thought john Krasinski. That's ri like we could talk about him. So's right. We didn't feel like we could talk about these scenes without him. So we did. We called him and he joined us. So guys, this is like we chitty chatted with John for a good 45 minutes. We're gonna let it play out here for you.
Enjoy. Guys, I watched an office episode for the first time in so long for this. Yeah. I haven't watched one for a little while now. And that one in particular, that's some heavy machinery of content. Yeah. Yeah. That was some heavy machinery. We just threw. Yeah. That was some heavy machinery. We just threw you in the deep end, John. We were like, here, watch this one.
Yeah, seriously. And I was like, first of all, I went through a time portal. I was like, who is that child? And I was talking about Jenna. And then I saw some furry, you know, wood nymph come in looking at me. Man, we were young once, weren't we? Wasn't that nice?
Yeah. Well, man, that was nice way back then. This is the first time I've watched Casino Night since it aired. Same. Yeah. Did we watch it at Greg's? I think we did.
We did. We did. I wrote in my journal that he had a viewing party and we all went over. Oh my God, do you have a journal? What am I doing with my life? Does she have a journal? Let me show you what my mic sits on so I can reach it because I'm shorty. Like seven journals. Like with Holly Hobby on the front. John, this is, that's who I was. I mean, come on. Oh my God. Wait, who you were? That seems like a current journal that is being written about right now. I'm writing right now.
By the way, speaking of Polly Pocket or whatever, Holly Hobby, either one of those E's, it made me think of that kid sister thing before I signed on. I was like, I had all these like sputtering memories that were like, remember this? And I blacked out for about 20 minutes. Okay. So I told on the podcast that we would do bits between scenes, kind of keep us going, that you really kept us all going.
You really did. And then I said we would do this kid sister big brother bit. And Jenna was like, wait, where did that come from? What was that about? You're like 1983 is where it came from. I know. But it was, John, wasn't it because there was like a doll that was about my height?
Oh no, you were the identical replica of kid sister. And they had it was a kid was a big brother. No, no, something I would go. You I would yell around the no, there was a boy one. And then they came out with a girl one that looked exactly like you. And I was at a store one day and saw it on a toy store like shelf. And I took a photo of myself standing next to it and I sent it like you. And I was at a store one day and saw it on a toy store, like shelf, and I took a photo of myself standing next to it and I sent it to you.
You were like, oh my God. Oh, I remember that, yes. But also you're the exact size of it, compared to me especially, you're like the perfect. And I remember one day, didn't you do like the stiff arms and stuff? And I like picked you up and you were like, yeah, oh, it was great.
It was good times. Someone, a fan wrote in and said, if you ever came on, could you and I do the bit? And I was like, well, I it's a pretty kid sister. Big brother. Oh, there it is. There it is. Jenna, what jokes did we have? We didn't get along well. What was it for us? Oh, boy. What were our bits?
What were our bits? What were our bits? Did we have bits? Boy, we had so many bits. You know what I remember bits-wise was many different inside jokes of like writing on Post-It notes and like all my memos that I had to hand to you for corporate, always had something written on them.
John, you played one prank on me in the whole nine years of the office. Like, one, like, really fully formed, good, thought-out prank. It was at Shroot Farms, and you and I had this scene where we had to drive up to the farmhouse several times.
And we're doing it, and I am getting increasingly more hot. I'm, like like warm. I'm sweating. I'm like, oh my god. I'm like, you're so hot. And we had to turn off the AC for sound and you were like, yeah, I don't know. I'm okay, but you're hot, huh? And I'm like, I'm so hot. This went on for like 15 minutes and then all of a sudden you start snickering and you had turned on my seat warmer all the way to the hottest setting. Oh my god, that was late in the run, wasn't it? That was late in the run. And I, but I was so excited because whenever we would go on
talk shows, they would always ask us if we played pranks on each other. And I would always say no. And I mean, say no and I mean not really I mean besides just like little jokes on post-it notes or something. I'm terrible. Not really. I'm terrible at pranks. We weren't pranky you know but then finally after you did that in the car I was like oh my gosh this is great I can finally have a prank to talk about.
Are you sad about that prank? What's sad about that prank? What's sad about that prank? I realized that I'm such a bad prankster that I stole that prank from Clooney when we were doing Leatherheads. He did that to me. So that's how unoriginal I am.
I was like, I'm going to take George Clooney's bat and do it to Jenna. And I thought that would make me cool. So basically, you're that. You got Clooney is what you got. I did one degree of separation. I think that prank just keeps getting cooler.
Like that's pretty fancy. I think so too, yeah. That's a good prank. Let's get into the meat of your interview here, John. I thought we were doing pretty good. We were, but we should intro you a little. John, thank you so much for coming on the show. We always like to ask our guests a little bit about how they came to be on The Office. And I
know you've told this story like a million times, but is it true that you were originally asked to audition for Dwight? Yes, I was. And that reminds me that about six seasons into the show someone was like I love how you say Dwight and I was like, how do you say it? And they were like Dwight and I was like, I know Dwight and they were like, nope Dwight and I was like, no, no, I'm saying it right. It's Dwight and they were like, nope It's not so um, yes I auditioned or no I was offered to come in and audition for the role of Dwight and I
was so excited. I had met Alison Jones randomly out in LA on a general meeting when I had zero dollars to my name and she said something's coming on our first meeting, our only meeting. She said something's coming called The Office. She'd be great for it. I said great. So then I got back to New York and they said, there's this show called The Office. And I was like, oh my God, Alison Jones, the greatest human ever told me about this. And they said, you're going in for the role of Dwight. And I had been a huge fan of the British show.
And I was like, I don't know, man. That's not, I don't know if I'm right for that role. And so I weirdly have no idea what I was thinking. I said, you know what? I read the thinking. I said, you know what? I read the pilot and I said, you know what, I'm gonna put my best foot forward. Let me know when they're casting Jims. And I remember the response from the NBC casting director
to my manager at the time was, no, but honestly, who does he think he is? Like passing up an audition, an opportunity to audition. And lo and behold, I thought it was over. And I think it was like five, six weeks later that they called and they were like all right they're looking for Jim's now and they'll have you back and then my gosh crazy and then when we finally did our screen test you you were living in New York and you had to fly to LA for that screen test with all these New Yorkers that were auditioning,
which was so much fun. I remember I took the plane with Jim Gaffigan, who was auditioning for a role and was like laughing. I mean, just was surrounded by heroes on the plane and then got to the callback or the test or whatever they called it. Cause I'm so experienced now, I have no idea what I'm talking about. But I remember getting in this big room
and it was the waiting room of where we actually shot our pilot. I'm sure you guys have covered that, but like where we shot our pilot is what they measured down to the quarter inch or centimeter to make our set, this building that existed. We took an existing building. And I remember sitting basically where like Ryan's desk, no, like where Mindy's desk was, like Toby and Mindy's
desk was. I was sitting against that wall and I saw all these other people coming in. I'd been there for like an hour or two hours and all the other people were the LA people. I realized they had separated us. And so they were asking the New York people to leave after they were done. And then I was the last New York person. And I saw all these LA people in and I started to get super self-conscious. I am not a confident person. And I was like, oh my God, this is so embarrassing. I'm the only New Yorker here. Because everybody was like, hey, Johnny, Tim, like greeting each other. And I was sitting on a floor. Like, so I went on to the set because all the producers were hiding in the background
and I said I'm so sorry I think someone forgot to tell me to go home and from behind a like fake wall I remember hearing like a lot of chair moving and stuff and like banging against the wall and it was Greg trying to get out of his chair and find the entrance to get back on set and he was like no hold on one second hold on one second please hold on one second and I heard Terry Weinberg being like, no, no, no, no, no, don't go. And then I went back out to the waiting room, super freaked out, and I saw Jenna walk in the door.
And she was like, as soon as I saw you walk in, Jen, I know I've told the story of building time, so people are like, we get it. We've seen behind the scenes. I genuinely had like a metaphysical event where I was like, oh, that's who's in the show. That person will be in the show. And so they held me back. You went in with a bunch of people. And I remember thinking, if I don't go in with her, I'm screwed. And that's when I went on the thing and said, you should let me go. And they said, no, no, no, there's one more person we want
you to audition with. And it was you. And I thought, oh my god, you're saying there's a chance because if I'm in with you, I knew I had a shot. Oh my god, John, I can go back to that moment that I saw you at the audition and I had that exact same reaction. I, it was, I've tried to describe it to people, like what it was like to audition with you. And the best, like the best explanation I could come up with was like, what if you walked into a room and music started playing and you and another person just started dancing in unison, even though you'd never met. That's what it was like auditioning with you. Wow, that's really way more beautiful than what I would say, which is like, I felt like I could see the future.
I was like, it actually gave me anxiety because I was like, she's so on the show. It's so weird that I'm like watching a piece get in. And I remember, I'm sure you remember too, but went after our audition and I loved auditioning with you. We were walking through the kitchen. And I said, because that was the way out. And I said, I just got to let you know,
I think that you're going to get this part. You're perfect for this. And you seem to remember, you said the same thing to me. I don't, because I blacked out. I was trying to not look you in the eyes. I did. I was so excited that you said that, because I felt like I had wanted to say that to you,
but I didn't have the courage. Because I didn't know you, you were like essentially a stranger to me. The only time we had really spoken or interacted was during our audition. So we were kind of silently walking back to the kitchen and I was thinking in my head, should I tell him I think he's the best gym?
Is that appropriate? Should I say you're the best gym, you're gonna be gym? Or is that bad form? I don't know, what's the etiquette? And so when you said, I think you're gonna best gym, you're going to be gym? Or is that bad form? I don't know, what's the etiquette? And so when you said, I think you're going to get the role of Pam, my memory is that I was like, oh my God, I think you're going to be gym,
you're the best gym, you're my favorite gym. Like that I just like blurted, I had like this just- Yeah, I was having a nosebleed at that time, don't remember much. But I do remember this though, that, you know, I always say this and people are like, yeah, whatever, but it's true. I have a lottery ticket life ever since I was given the news that I was on that show.
Everything changed in my life from every single way, not to get into a heady version, but like not only every opportunity that I've ever had is from the show. I met my wife because she knew who I was in a restaurant for a show. We never would have been in the same city or restaurant or anything. It was, it's just so crazy how deep and crazy it goes. But I remember at the epicenter of it all, when I was told that I had the part, I actually jumped on a couch. And then like, like, again, this metaphysical thing came over me where I went, wait, wait, wait, one second. Um, did Jenna Fisher get the part of Pam? And they were like, over me where I went, wait, wait, wait, one second. Did Jenna Fisher get the part of Pam?
And they were like, we don't know. We just told you your life changed. Are you happy enough with that? And I was like, no, you need to call them back and ask if Jenna got the part. Cause I thought if you were on it, then I was going to be on one of the best things that I'll ever do in my life.
And if they were like, no, you know, Rhonda something whatever got it. And I'd be like, no, not Rhonda. Well, when, whatever got it. And I'd be like, no, not Rhonda. Well, when they called me and told me that I got the part, I had a very similar reaction. And the first question I asked was, did John Krasinski get the role of Jim? Because I just felt like, I don't know if I can do Pam without you as Jim. So I was like, I need to know, did my, did my partner in crime get this part? And they were like, yes, he did.
And what's weird is that that's the first question he asked after he was told. He asked- And by the way, we never saw each other after the kitchen. I left. No, we didn't have each other's phone numbers. We couldn't text each other or email.
So it was like, then I just waited until the pilot table read when we were all reunited each other or email. So it was like, then I just waited until the pilot table read when we were all reunited. Same with Rain. I only met Rain at the audition. And when I heard he got the role, I was like, well, that tracks because he was definitely the weirdest dude. Oh my god.
I remember thinking, I remember doing this audition with Rain where Greg asked me to ask him to cover my phones and of course he said to Rain under no circumstances will you cover his phones and I remember being like hey Dwight will you just cover my phone I just got to go to the bathroom and he was like sorry and then pretended to close barn doors and then I asked him again and he did like like shipping container doors and I kept doing it. And by the end of it, not to Dwight, to the actor Rain, I was like, you are infuriating. You're an infuriating human.
And I was like, he's gonna get it. Well, oh my gosh. It's so good to talk to you. All of that just makes my heart happy, you guys. Hearing all that, I don't know that I've, you know, I've heard snippets of those stories, but I've never heard all of it and watched you guys tell it is actually really beautiful just go no I was gonna say I've
actually never told those stories with you in I was gonna say in person or not in digital form the same I feel like we've told those stories separately on talk shows or interviews, but actually never to one another. Yeah, it's like there's always these things where you're like, is that what happened? It's so interesting. So amazing. I have so many stories that I'm like, I wonder if people know that.
It's like some of my favorite stuff is like sort of, I guess it's a secret, but I don't know. Oh, like one of my favorite stories I ever tell you this story was when we wrapped by the way how dare Greg Daniels do that rap remember that when he was like yeah I just got to get you guys leave in the office a couple times for I got to cut it into the earlier part of the show and we were all just totally goofing off and laughing heading to like for Richard is like and then when we came back he was standing there
all weird remember that yeah and it was like that that was the last take of anything he was like ladies and gentlemen I just want to tell you that the show has concluded or the office is over that's a wrap that's a wrap and I was like and I definitely threw up on my shoes someone took a picture of that moment I don't know who it was but we're all getting that picture we're disintegrating we're like all of us't know who it was, but we're all disintegrating. We're like all of us. It was like some weird, incredibly smart move to like,
just, cause we all knew it was coming. And then he did the smartest thing by being like, oh shoot, I got to do this one more thing. Like just get out of the office, walk a couple of times. I just need you to exit. And I remember Randall being weird, so he must've been in on it. And then when Greg came out, I remember we looked in all the crew. Everyone that had been in Video Village had come out on the stage.
And they were all sort of. That's right. Yeah. And I was just like, what's happening? We all ended like together. Like it was so intense. It was like, I'm your dad and I'm leaving you. And you're like, what? Um, but the funny thing was that day. It was like, I'm your dad and I'm leaving you. And you're like, what? But the funny thing was that day, everybody was really emotional and we had the wrap party. And so everybody was like trying to get themselves together.
And I think of myself as a somewhat moral person. And I had the weirdest idea when I got back to the trailer, I was crying like crazy. And I went, oh, my God, there's one thing I want. If like, like, what's the one thing you would want from the show. And I ran back and stole the Dunder Mifflin sign that we all did talking head suit. And I got, dude, and then I think, I think I did tell you Jenna, cause I was like, so Catholic. I was like, must tell someone.
And then we got to the party and I'll never forgive myself. I don't even know if he knows it. We're at the party and I saw Greg and I was like, Greg, thank you for my whole life and like whatever. And he was like, yeah, yeah, no problem. And I was like, how you doing? He goes, I'm good, you know, I'm a little bummed. The one thing I wanted was the Dunder Mifflin sign. He goes, but someone took it.
And literally my brain exploded and I went, that sucks, man. Whoever did that, that sucks. I remember saying to him, I lied to my dad. I lied to my TV creator. Oh my god. I lied to his face. I remember you loading out your trailer and I walked out and I have a visual of you putting it in your car. It was very large.
That's how I knew. That's how I knew. Because I only had like a bath towel and that didn't even begin to cover it. It was just like, it was the worst heist of all time. And I also remember people being like, why is John leaving so fast? And I was like, don't look at me! Like as I drove out of the parking lot, it was so weird. Do you remember the big sign that, well, it was like a fake painting of me looking angry that hung in the senator's house. Oh yeah. The art department gave that to me.
It's enormous. It's the size of a small loveseat sofa. If we're sharing secrets, I'll say that I asked if I could have Pam's watercolor of Dunder Mifflin. And I was told officially from production that I could not have it because it was gonna be cataloged as part of like the set decoration and it would be stored at NBC.
And no, I couldn't have it. I was really heartbroken because besides a couple of trinkets on my desk and like a few pieces of wardrobe, I really hadn't saved anything else. That was really the one thing I wanted. And oh my gosh, I'm gonna cry a little bit. As I was leaving, Phil Shea ran up to me and he said,
here, you should have this. I made a color photo of it. They'll never know. I have the original in my house. Oh my it? Oh my God! That's amazing. Dude, Phil Shea is the reason I have anything. He sent me a box like years, like three or four years later, of my bag, my nameplate. Your satchel that you would carry?
Yeah, my satchel, my nameplate, and the teapot, bro. You have the teapot! You have the teapot! You have the teapot! We have been wondering who has the teapot! You have the teapot! You have the teapot! We have been wondering who has the teapot! Teapot son! Son of a gun! Wow!
Oh man, I thought you knew that! I didn't know it was a great caper! She said, I have always wondered who got that teapot! You know what's so funny is I had the greatest idea because I heard your amazing podcast about the teapot? I've always wondered. You know what's so funny is I had the greatest idea because I heard your amazing podcast about the teapot episode and I was going to take a picture of it in my room and totally forgot. I wanted to like post it right after I had heard your episode.
Oh my gosh, that would have blown my mind. Yeah. I'm sure there's a couple because in case anyone broke, you could probably get one, I'm sure. I know, but you have the teapot. That's huge. So there you go. So John, we are currently on the scene outside in the parking lot where Jim,
yeah, Roy just took off in his truck. Yeah, said, told me to keep an eye on you. Remember that? Yeah. Jenna's dressed as a bridesmaid Jenna looks like I am I remember talking to Jenna about this a couple times about like how Jenna's take on it was like or for Pam's take whatever she was like a little saucy of Jim to be like you got it like a little devious right from the beginning like this nice guy was like
oh you bet I'll take care of her oh I'll take care of her. No, I remember that that that moment in particular was insane for so many reasons because I remember how again, I keep talking about this like metaphysical thing, but I remember that like the cells of my body were really buzzing because I saw the crew running around and deciding where to hide the cameras. And Ken Quapus was our director and was phenomenal and making it feel like, it's no big deal, we're just doing a scene of a show
that'll never be seen. And then you're like, I think it's gonna be more than that. And he was like, who cares, just do it. Like he was trying to keep it so low. And I remember you and I were in a stair be more than that. He was like, who cares, just do it. Like he was trying to like keep it so low. And I remember you and I were in like a stairwell or something waiting. Yeah. And everybody was deciding, do you do the cameras?
Can they see the cameras? Can they not see the cameras? Meaning Jim and Pam, can they see the cameras, whatever? Are they aware of the documentary crew? And I remember, I think it was Ken, right? Who just said, I think I'm gonna make the decision that they don't. And I remember Matt, I think I remember this. Again, I'm elderly, but I feel like Ken placed the cameras
and didn't tell us exactly where they were gonna be. That sounds like Ken. Well, there was this big argument that went back to even when the script came out, which was should we film this scene with video or with audio only? Like this idea. And I think the reason we were in a stairwell
for a very long time, John, was because they were deciding if we should have walked inside and gone onto the stairwell and we said the lines and right when we got to the end of the scene the camera would find us and we would be looking at each other in silence. Yes the idea was that Randall would be running to try to get it on film. Yes and that was kind of like Greg wanted that and like half the writers wanted that. Yeah. Imagine how good the show could have been if that was the case.
I know. But instead. We could have succeeded. But then, and by the way, on Wikipedia, it claims that we shot that footage and it has never been seen, but that's not true. We never shot that. We only rehearsed it. I don't remember ever shooting a version.
Do you? Yeah, I thought we rehearsed it. And then I thought, what I do remember maybe vaguely is that Ken was like, and if we do that version, we'll have the audio, so don't worry about it. Remember? Like I remember Ken, I think was saying to Greg, like, listen, Greg, the good news is if we do end up going that route,
we will already have the audio. Let's just shoot it out here first. And it was like a Jedi mind trick to get Greg to go with it. Right. But I do remember that they did, another reason we were in the stairwell was so that they were going to set the cameras outside. And when we came out, we wouldn't
know where the cameras were. Right. And I remember feeling very alone in the parking lot. Well, again, because all the crew was kind of buzzy about it and like, hello. And like, all our great friends that I would be. I remember I was at the craft service table, not for this scene, but the next scene.
And it's like, I remember going like, hey, Chris. Ooh, we were in fantasy football, one of my favorite people, Chris Workman. And I was like, hey, Chris. And he was like, hello, John. And then moved. And I was like, whoa, I don't think he's ever used the full word hello ever. That was the weirdest thing I've ever heard. Like everybody was so buzzed up about that. I don't remember this, Jenna. Do you have any semblance of an idea of how many takes of that we did? because I remember genuinely being extremely nervous,
which I was like, this will be great for the scene, because I think it was probably, or at least I had probably interpreted it as the biggest scene I had done on the show, or something to that level of intensity, was like super terrifying to me, and I remember in my head being like, hey bro, remember when you thought you were an actor tonight ruins that whole mirage
And oh hardly I was so I was so nervous to do that scene, but actually watching it again today It was really amazing because we were like kind of standing close to each other and it was like it was all very Awkward and perfect. It was so good. I wrote in my journal, oh my God, John Krasinski, and that tear, oh my God. I have it, I'm gonna screen grab it and send it to you, John. Please. Oh my God, you wrecked us, you wrecked me. You were so good.
Both you guys were so good. I think I also remember Ken being such a good director. I was like, you know, so in this scene, how you feeling? And, you know, how you feeling? And, and I was like, yeah, good. I said, you know, I'm going to be really honest with you, Ken. This is, this is a layup for me, bro, because I lived it. And he was like, what do you mean? And I was like, dude, in my high school yearbook, I have every single girl in the school being like, thank you so much, you are the shoulder to cry on.
You were such a good friend when I was in love with Adam, like all this stuff, bro, I was like, no problem. So then when he was like, hey, do a scene about the love of your life, having another guy instead of you. And I was like, bro, it's called my default setting. Well, I, I remember shivering because I was freezing. It was really cold out and I was in that little dress and desert night. Oh, it was chilly. And I also, so here, here was something that I traded some messages with Ken Quapus about this scene.
And he reminded me that we had actually filmed the kiss the night before. What? Yeah, we filmed the kiss the day before. And that this was the very final thing we shot for casino night. It took longer than any other scene. We spent more time on it than any other scene. We spent more time on it than any other scene. And we played around with the dialogue. So I have the script too. And
what's in the script is a little different. And the thing is, is that that's my memory. I remember when I think back, the scene we were most nervous about was this scene. And people always ask about the kiss, but this was the scene we worked hardest on and it makes sense to me saying I'm in love with you is such a vulnerable thing and you do it so honestly John and I also remember that those lines Where I was saying like oh do you want me to take your money now or I could take it later or when do it? That was all banter that we came up with on the spot. And that you were going to then like shock me out of.
And then I remember that stuff, that line where you said, when I'm like, I'm really sorry if you misinterpreted our friendship. And you're like, don't. When you said don't, that was an improv. And I like, my stomach, like my heart dropped into my stomach. I was like, oh my god, I'm so sorry. That's what I love is like you're doing this as Pam and as Jenny you're like, so sorry bro that was really rude. I was like everything. Like I was having to be Pam, but on the inside, I was like, I'm so sorry. Because you were, you know, and you, you cried in a couple of the takes, I remember.
But the one that they used, I think was the first time,, because it was so it wrecked me, it wrecked me. And I was like, my job is just stand here and stare at him. And after they yelled cut, I feel like I was like, I'm sorry. Oh, my god, I'm terrible. There you are saying telling us now that you were there being like, Oh, my god, I'm so sorry. And watching it back today, I was like, Jesus, cold as ice. Like that was- She's so cold-hearted. That was cold-blooded.
That was so- It was cold, but I also think Pam was just like, and listen, John, I always defend Jim. Like throughout our podcast, when anything happens, I'm like, Pam is horrible. Poor Jim. She does. But in this moment, I really saw her as just totally completely
was deer in headlights. Like, everything was so real now. And once it's out there, it is out there, you know, and all of a sudden, she's gonna have to be accountable. Yes, I felt the same way watching it back. I was like, because I remember it differently. I remember like there were like three more moments in casino night of us flirting. And then when my man turns around and is like, I just want to tell you something. You're like, that's so fast. Even me was like, hey man, that is bad game. Stop.
You know what though, the scene that I loved was, and I realized it didn't come out of the blue is because of Jan. And when she goes, did you tell anybody? And I was like, right, he has to tell her now because he can never do it again. That was awesome. Such good writing. Who are those people?
Also just like so kind. Like I feel like our, like Greg and Ken, like they were so gracious to let us have room to find those moments. You know, like they really like guys playing around. Right from the beginning. Like, we didn't need a lot of room after that. It was just so, but for those moments, you know, like they really like guys playing around right from the beginning. Like, yeah, we didn't need a lot of room after that. It's just so but for those moments, they were so respectful. So which again leads
to the second part, which is sorry, I'm jumping on your end. No, no, no, no, no, I'll move us along. But I wanted to say one more thing, which was when I was watching it back, I was like, what does Pam think Roy is secretly taping her or something? Like, she seemed like a spy who was like, I am very sorry, but I am loyal to Roy Anderson. I can't do this. You are a wonderful friend to me. But I obviously was impacting her because we're going to move into the bullpen and she goes up and calls her mom. To compliment your acting though, that, I mean, that has got to be my favorite thing
on any performance is when it's exactly what you imagine it would be, right? Because in the movies and TV, you're like, we've been programmed as kids to say that when someone says I love you, when you're sort of with someone else, you go, excuse me, how dare you in this whole dramatic thing. But instead your brain's just like, run the program, shut him down. Yeah. Like there's no emotion. Mayday, mayday, escape. Yes. Exactly.
Pull the cord. Pull the cord. Should we talk about the big old kiss? It's not even a big kiss. It's a little kiss, but it's the perfect kiss. It was substantial. It's also my first kiss., it's a little kiss, but it's the perfect kiss. It was substantial. It's also my first kiss. First kiss I ever had acting. That was my first acting kiss ever.
Mine was with Dwight. It was my second. Now that I say that, I'm wondering when else I would have had the opportunity, but like, no college play kissing, no nothing. That was nothing. Wow, that was your first on-screen kiss? My first fake kiss.
It was my second. I had done a movie called Born Champion. Oh. And I had a kiss scene in that. It was a sag, low-budget, I think maybe a non-union film. So I was one kiss more experienced than John. Which is a lot. I was so nervous.
And here's something that Ken Quapus reminded me, John. He said, let me find it. It was so sweet. Ken said, I remember the day we did the kissing scene, you and John were off the charts nervous. And he said, he felt like it was his job to be really casual about the scene to kind of undercut how momentous it was. And I remember that he was being super casual about it, but he said, but what didn't help was that on the shooting schedule, the scene description read, Jim kisses Pam in all caps, italics, and three exclamation points. This is what we trade for people. You're like, okay,
This is what we trade for people you're like, okay And I think probably the crew was given the notice of like guys keep it cool, right? Let's not mess this up because that's when Chris Workman was like holding a you know a Plate of like peanut butter pretzels or something was like it Whoa, John and then like walked away and I was like Chris What the hell was that? But I also remember you were in your trailer like walked away and I was like, Chris, what the hell was that? But I also remember you were in your trailer for a while and I thought you were upset because I was on stage all the time because I was usually around crafty and I had heard that you were in your trailer and I was like, is everything okay? And I didn't know what was happening.
And then I remember again, similarly, they told me that they were ready. And when I got on set, I was first on set at how I remember at least. I was first on set and was looking for Randall and Matt because I used to goof around with those guys. And weirdly, my default setting is like, make jokes when you're nervous. So I was looking for them and I was genuinely crestfallen when I couldn't find them because then I was looking for them and I was genuinely crestfallen when I couldn't find them, because then I was really nervous, because I was like, oh my God, if my bit machine isn't gonna work, then what do we do?
And then they were like, John, so you're gonna go to the front door? And I was like, front door, what's happening? And I got so, then I got so weirded out. And then someone came, I don't know if, was it Jazzmem was on yet? But I don't know, I think it was Jazz came up and was like,
and John, go. And I was like, I just remember like a person being like, and go. And it was like, I was in slow motion. I was like, do what? And I just went on and it was so weird. Well, I remember rehearsing. I'm gonna put that in quotes. I remember discussing the scene in the days prior. I had a bunch of meetings with Greg and you and Ken
where we all talked about it. Like, how big should the kiss be? I remember asking, how much does Pam kiss him back? We discussed that she would definitely allow herself to be kissed. And then, but did she really, like, kiss him back? How long should it go on? Like, just sort of general, chitty-chatness about how it would play out.
And then I remember on the day doing a very rough blocking of it, but alone. Like, when you were like, what is she doing in her trailer? They had brought me to set to rehearse by myself. This is where you're gonna stand at Jim's desk. There was a big discussion. Why am I not standing at reception?
It was because it would be too hard for you to get to me. They wanted to put the camera in the kitchen so that we couldn't see it. They would shoot it through the blinds. It would be super secret spy shot. And that was the best position. We worked out exactly how I would stand with the phone. And then they said, now we want you to go back to your
trailer and not leave until you're called. Oh, wow. And don't speak to john and be alone. And so it was super secret. Yes, they they talk about this in the DVD commentary guys. I wasn't there. But I listened to the DVD commentary commentary and they wanted to keep you guys apart That's yeah, that's something that they do. I think Like I'm reminiscing about it now with you and I remember one time talking to Brian about it years later And I was like, oh man, like I remember that was the the last thing we shot that day He goes no it was not and I was like, what are you talking about and he goes we were all in our trailers like oh god let's go we were in our trailer for like three hours like I took a nap
someone was like what is happening I know my memory is that that was the last thing we did that day me too and we could take as much time as we wanted not all of us were in our trailers being like, you gotta be kidding me with these two. Oh no! Oh no! I thought it was the end of the day and we were all the time in the world. That's what I said to Ryan! Oh my goodness. He's right. But I don't know, you guys, it was such an important scene. They had to find it. And in the commentary, they talk about how they wanted the first time that john is Jim saw Pam was in that moment on action. Yeah, that they never rehearsed it on the stage together. And
then I remember they brought me to set and all the lights were dim. There was no one around. It was super creepy. Yeah, that's right. So there was no one around. It was super eerie. Yeah, that was creepy. Yeah, that was, and that's what I mean. So there was no crew. And that's when they were like. Yeah. Nothing. And they were like. John, please move to the entrance. I was like, who is that?
Is that the devil? Who just saw him? I love that in your mind, John, it's like, slow down. You're like, you know. Yeah, but it's super like scary, like weird. And then Ken, I think, and Greg, were hiding maybe in the conference room in the very back corner with a little thing, like a little, I don't know what is that, like a handheld
video monitor that they could see what the camera is shooting. We only used one camera. It was only the camera in the kitchen. So it was a one shot. There was no way to cut. We had to get it all a one shot. There was no way to cut. We had to get it all in one shot. Mm-hmm. And I remember I'm doing the bit with my mom on the phone, and then you walked in, and we shot the kiss,
and then we're staring at each other, and Ken said, cut. And do you remember Greg? Do you remember Greg running out of the conference room like clapping his hands? He was like, he was giddy. He was like, Yeah, he was like, so good. It was so good. How many takes of that did we do? Three. Wow.
I know the commentary said that he put on sorry, I wrote it down. Greg said he picked the last take. The last take was his favorite. Oh, interesting! Ken Kwapis and Kent Zbornak both confirmed we only did three takes of this scene, and Ken said that Greg wanted to keep doing it over and over and over again and Ken had to convince him that we had it. Wow. But Greg was like, it's just so good. It's just so good.
And he wanted to keep doing it. And and Ken was like, no, we're going to wear them out. We're going to wear them out. That's obviously where the voice was coming from. I imagine Greg just being like, dance for me. You're like, what? You can't say that. Awkward. Awkward.
That's so weird. There's one other thing in the DVD commentary, you guys, I thought was really cool is that Randall Einhorn said that he really wanted it to end so that you couldn't see Pam's face. So you never knew what her reaction was after that. That's right. So that was really thought out that Jenna, you never looked around like you were facing this one way and Cameron never saw your face after the kiss.
Yeah, that was part of what he argued for only using one camera. That there was some discussion that another camera would come around by the front door and capture Pam's side of everything and sneak in. But he was like, no, I think we only managed to get one shot of this. So you don't know.
It was amazing. Yeah, crazy. It was beautiful, you guys. You guys crushed it. Guys, this was the most fun ever to talk about this. I mean. It was fun to reminisce. You guys, guys, congratulations on this podcast.
It is so much fun. And I don't think two other people could have done it. I mean, you guys guys congratulations on this podcast. It is so much fun and I don't think two other people could have done it. I mean you guys do such a good job. You're so nice. Thank you. Thanks so much. I don't know if there's two people from our show who like talking as much as us. Do you remember? Who talk constantly. Do you remember? Right now Brian's at home going like we know that's true. You're like Brian geez settle down. Do you remember how Rain would make fun of us? He would say, there they go. Baka-dika-baka-dika-baka.
Like, we'd be like. Yeah, Rain would be like, what more could you possibly have to say to one another? I know. God. Our crudgeon. Our curmudgeon. Our curmudgeon.
I love you both so much. Thank you so much for doing. Thanks for having me. We love you, John. Thanks for coming on. That was so great. We hope you enjoyed it as much as we did. Yeah.
Thank you, John. John Krasinski, you're the best. He is the best. He is the best. But Jenna, before we say goodbye, there are one or two moments that fans wrote in about. We have to talk about the phone call between Pam and her mom. We have to talk about this moment. Yes we got so much mail about this. Erin Louise, Matt Loveless, Mrs. Prince, Brianna and EJ.
They all wanted to know if there was another side to this phone call. Mm-hmm. Well I'll tell you this guys, there was no one on the other line. Jenna, I was just pretending. And the Emmy goes to Jenna Fisher. My God, that's some good phone talk, lady. Yeah, no one was there. No one was there. I invented in my head what the dialogue was.
Yeah. And I had written it down in my script for what I thought my mom was saying to me so that I would have good reactions and I was going through it in my head as I was doing the scene. That's me applauding my BFF. Oh my gosh. Thank you. Yeah. So there was one line in particular that everyone honed in on, which is when Pam says, yeah, I think I am. Yeah. What was she responding to? I mean, I know what I thought.
I think I know what all the fans think. What do you think? I think I am in love with him. That is what I had written in my script, that my mom asked me, well, sweetie, are you in love with him. That is what I had written in my script that my mom asked me, well, sweetie, are you in love with him? Yeah. And that I answered, yeah, mom, I think I am. Oof. Yeah. Oh, Pam. And then we got a fan question. A lot of people actually asked this question. Alyssa Dunn, Carrie Harvey and
more wanted to know if we knew what the next season would bring to the Jim Pam storyline when we shot those scenes in the parking lot and in the in the office. Right. No we did not. We were not told what would happen to them. It was a cliffhanger to the cast as well. I have to think that Greg probably had a few ideas and didn't want to tell us anything until it would become more concrete for him what the plan was, you know? Mm-hmm.
I would think. I think he had an idea that they were gonna have Jim go to Stanford. Well, yeah. But a few weeks before we went back into production for the season three, I did get called in to do a bunch of chemistry read auditions with possible Karens. And that was my first insight into what was going to happen in season three.
Oh, that's juicy. That would have been that's like good intel back then because we were all clueless. We didn't know what was gonna happen. I think another cliffhanger is, obviously the Dwight Angelo was happening with them, but then also what is gonna happen with Jan and Michael? Because you see that Jan actually did pack an overnight bag in her car.
Yes, yes. As she's leaving, the camera finds this overnight bag. She was 100% planning to hook up with Michael. Yeah, and just sleep over at his place Which is a big deal. Well, I did hear in the DVD commentary that it was this episode that Melora Hardin and David Denman Became series regulars. So we knew that they were gonna be coming back, but we didn't know how. Wow, there we go. There we go guys, that was a big, big episode. We hope you enjoyed it.
We certainly enjoyed getting to watch it again and talk to John and all the cast members we texted and Kintapedia. Thank you so much for giving us such great behind the scenes moments. Yes, and guys, after we did that interview with John, Angela and I were a part of his show, Some Good News. It was so much fun.
First of all, my family and I are such huge fans of Some Good News. We've watched every episode, and what John is doing, the goodness he's putting out there is so wonderful. And Jenna, wasn't it a blast? It was so much fun. If you guys haven't seen it, you have to check it out. There's this couple, their names are John and Susan Lush.
They're from Maryland. And when they got engaged, they reenacted Jim and Pam's engagement at the gas station. But then because of the pandemic, their May wedding was canceled. So John surprised them. We might have recreated the dance down the aisle from Jim and Pam's wedding.
And it was just so much fun and such a wonderful thing to be a part of. Yeah, the thing that John is doing with that, it's just, it's great. He's bringing some light and love to the world. And John, we love you. We love you. And you guys, we will see you next week
with Can You Believe It? The first episode of season three, Gay Witch Hunt. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins,
and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.